und da geht es eigentlich um die
atomkraft also ich will das mal relativ
kurz machen damit wir uns dann auch
richtig schöne streiten können was mich
seit einiger zeit ärgert ist die
tabuisierung eines themas alles andere
ist inzwischen kein tabu mehr weder die
bundeswehr ausrüstung dringend
überfällig viel zu lange verschlampt
worden von einer großen koalition
auch ein tabuthema das so langsam fällt
ist dass man immer mehr klimaschutz
machen muss was ja im kern auch richtig
ist nur wenn ich den ukraine konflikte
hier wenn ich sehe dass wir im grunde
entweder selbst ein energie embargo
machen müssen weil wir so unter druck
geraten dass das die anderen von uns als
beweis von solidarität fordern oder aber
der herr im kreml einfach mal sagt lasst
mich doch nicht von den western jetzt
hier vorführen drehe ich den geldhahn zu
dann haben wir probleme mit der
energieversorgung
in einer solchen situation
einfach zu sagen wir diskutieren über
alles auch über eine verlängerung der
laufzeiten für kohlekraftwerke
aber überhaupt nicht über eine
verlängerung der laufzeit dieser letzten
drei atommeiler vielleicht auch noch
eine wiederbelebung der gerade ende des
jahres stillgelegt meiner weil wir die
stromversorgung und dafür gilt ja nur
die kernenergie dadurch deutlich
absichern können das was wir dann noch
an kohle und gas brauchen halt in die
anderen prozesse zu machen ich weiß auch
mit kerner die kann ich kein auto fahren
und ich kann auch meine heizung nicht
betreiben aber ich kann die
stromversorgung weitgehend sichern über
das maß hinaus und muss nicht umschalten
jetzt kommt das argument kenne ich auch
brennelemente
also selbst und wenn die mode der stelle
wir kriegen die nicht so schnell die
neuen die man braucht selbst wenn man
jetzt sagt okay dann drosseln wir
die nutzung der kernenergie im sommer
und ersetzen das durch kohle dann habe
ich ja immer noch die chance dass ich in
den winter wo es drauf ankommen wo jeder
merkt wenn es kalt wird in der wohnung
und wo ich keinen strom mehr hat um
irgendwas in lotte nicht zu haben und
dergleichen dann kann ich das nutzen
ganz abgesehen davon dass ich ohnehin
glaube dass man sehr wohl brennelemente
besorgen kann wenn man es denn will und
die politik es weh wenn die etwas will
kann sie ja anderes sehr deutlich machen
mich ärgert dass darüber nicht
diskutiert wird weil es einen grüne dna
ist und man wohl die sorge hat mein gott
den grünen wird jetzt schon so viel
zugemutet da können wir nicht nur das es
geht um mich nicht misszuverstehen nicht
darum dass die nächsten zehn jahre
atommeiler laufen es geht mir um diese
überbrückungszeit in der jetzigen durch
den ukraine krieg und die
unberechenbarkeit von wladimir putin
entstandene situation und da freihändig
zu sagen das brauchen wir nicht halte
ich für leichtfertig ja ich habe einen
gewissen stolz denn die leute gehen sie
haben die nämlich damals genehmigt die
drei die sie jetzt genannt dann habe ich
mit meiner unterschrift genehmigt und
ich habe damals ein
freund genscher der parteivorsitzende
mal gefragt kann ich das macht meine
fachleute reaktorsicherheit im
innenministerium haben sehr sorgfältig
das vorbereitet ist ein konvoi sind nach
einem gleichen baumuster genehmigt wird
jede schraube genehmigt so also ganz
billig und da hat er mir gesagt herr
baum wenn sie das nicht können dann
müssen sie alle laufenden atommeiler
sofort abstimmen denn die die sie jetzt
auf dem tisch haben zur genehmigung sind
noch wesentlich sicherer als die
verloren also die sind alle sich aber im
grunde müssen sie jetzt sich fragen
steigen sie außer wenn sie nicht wohl
wenn sie das nicht wollen steigen sie
aus der atomenergie aus und ich kann
jetzt nicht mehr primär sagen wie man
die jetzt wieder
wichtigen kann was ich damals nur
bedauert habe dass wir aus der ganzen
technologie ausgestellt und es gibt ja
mehr die ganze technologie geht darüber
hinweg da sind wir ausgestiegen in einer
paniksituation
ich habe mir große anstrengungen
unternommen die entsorgung sicher die
bis heute nicht sichergestellt ich habe
dieser tage mal eine regierungserklärung
nachgelesen sich 1979 abgegeben habe da
habe ich an die länder appelliert doch
ein endlager zur verfügung der einzige
der das gemacht hat bei herr albrecht
ist auf die schnauze gefallen mit gordon
mit gorleben dann sind wir nach bayern
haben unsere augen sich nach bayern
gerichtet keiner wollte das bis heute
der einzige der das mal ehrlich
angesprochen hatte beck das gehört
nämlich auch dazu und das obszöne an der
ganzen sache ist in kuba in zeiten der
knappheit kaufen wir atomstrom von
kontron nachbarn also wir haben den
ausstieg falsch organisiert würde ich
mal sagen und mir die ganze
klimageschichte hängt ja daran dass wir
gas kraftwerke bauen im übergang ja ja
und da finden wir das kriegen wirklich
und trans sie ist jetzt ins wasser
gefallen und jetzt steht man da und sah
man wer in die ganze für den ganzen
transformation klimaneutralität an um an
den gaskraftwerken müssen neue gebaut
werden aber da müssen wir jetzt ganz
auch kriegen wenn die russen und ja das
ist vorbei dann ist es vorbei dann gehen
wir auch in polen gab werke wie pervers
ist es eigentlich ausgerechnet von den
grünen dann die kohlekraftwerke
wieder zu reaktivieren oder die jetzigen
einfach laufen zu lassen wenn man doch
so erhole und dem klimaschutz so hoch
hält den co2 ausstoß meint ich muss mir
neu dass ein atommeiler co2 ausscheiden
ist das tun die kohlekraft habe aber
herr premier
darüber nicht gesprochen wird ist völlig
falsch wenn sie mal geschaut haben auf
den tagesordnungspunkt es gab in den
letzten wochen verschiedenste anträgen
zu dem thema in ausschüssen wird das
diskutiert das thema wurden durchaus
diskutiert und behandelten wird aber
haben als er seine ist eine thema mit
dem uran das haben sie selber
angesprochen mit den brennstäben das
zweite thema ist die sicherheit also
alle sicherheitsgenehmigungen für die
atom laufwetter auslaufen aus obwohl uns
die letzten fünf jahre nicht investiert
worden es muss erst mal investiert
werden da müssen eine neue abnahme
erfolgen denn ich glaube da rein will
doch ohne abstimmung sicherheit es
möchten ohne abgenommene sicherheits
nein
man muss es nachher wenn das nicht offen
ist und auch der müll jetzt mal ich also
dann man sehr sorgfältig prüfen
ich freue mich ja prima dass sie das so
ansprechen weil ja es ist irgendwo
trotzdem noch so ein bisschen tabu auch
in der medialen darstellung aber in
einer solchen krisensituation wo die
preise für energie explodieren und die
bürger sie quasi nicht mehr zahlen und
die leute in den ratschlag geben ihr
sonst frieren und so war es da kann es
doch nicht sein dass wird die die lauf
und funktionieren dass man nicht in der
lage ist und die betreiber haben es
inzwischen ja auch eingeräumt dass es
geht dass man neue sicherheitskontrollen
macht und wenn es geht ihnen auch mal
drei vier jahre laufen lässt voll
produzieren lassen als das feuer dann
ist es halt nach hoya aber wir haben wir
festgestellt haben des jahres ja ist ja
und das ist auch so getätigt wenn
wir heute verfolgen ich habe meinen
arsch auf eimer
bremer ja ich wollte dir nur sagen er
heute ich habe ein ganz tolles gefühl
dass bei diesem beispiel auch bei
anderen dinge die man eigentlich
politisch nicht so gern will aus
rücksicht auf irgendwen in diesem fall
also auf die grünen und die deshalb
favorisiert ist da bestreitet man die
tabuisierung und sagt wir diskutieren
das ja in ausschüssen und das geht da
auch hin und her und dann kommt
plötzlich die ganzen gegenargumente und
das thema ist wieder weg sie diskutieren
es nicht mit dem ziel es möglich zum
genauso gern möglichst unmöglich zu
machen denn das ist eine unfaire bürger
haltung bei einem thema das jetzt unter
den nägeln brennt wollen sie
verantworten glauben sie wirklich dass
die deutschen alle noch so toll dafür
sind dass wir alles mögliche für die
ukraine machen wenn sie das in den
nächsten winter keinen strom mehr haben
also erstmal erstmal haben ein riesiges
entlastung zwei riesige entlastungs
paket also gefragt gekommen und die
erstmal die bevölkerung entlastet weil
die hohen preise habe ich das auch nicht
gern in der liga ist ja auch finanziell
oder zweiter und schimpfen also
unterbreitete holen oder sagt wir
anderen ja eine riesige chance haben
jetzt die energiewende voranzubringen
jetzt mit dem frühjahr und im sommer und
im herbst paket wirken die klimawende
mit windenergie mit pv energie voran zu
bringen und dort wesentlich unabhängiger
zu werden und wesentlich ambitionierter
voranschreiten zu können aber als je
geplant hatten ich möchte eine braucht
mir keiner gerne stellen ein herr baum
und zwar das tabuthema haben wir jetzt
hier schon aufgebrochen aber wer ist
eigentlich zu grün wenn man erst mal so
ausdrücken will die presse oder die
politik also wie kommt denn eigentlich
diese entwicklung beides ja also ich
habe eben hat der bremer ja die kritiker
kritisiert der ganzen letzten jahre und
das hat jemand anders reagiert also ich
bitte die öffentlichkeit auch mal sich
an die eigene nase zu fassen wo wann die
themen ja zum beispiel in bayern lese
ich da werden keine
überlandleitung genehmigt seit jahren
nicht sie kriegen den windstrom nicht
von norden und dass das eher weil die
bevölkerung dagegen es wir sind in
nordrhein westfalen beispielsweise
zugepflastert mit diesen dingern ja sie
also und es gibt jetzt ist eine
augenblick situation wo sich die markt
wo die meinung kippen aber die
öffentliche meinung die meinung die auch
angestoßen werden müsste von den medien
war auch nicht da wo waren die
diskussion über die atomenergie vorher
ist ja jetzt auch nicht dafür
recht wenn sie sagen ich möchte eine
zielorientierte politik ich gehe ich bin
bei ihnen wenn sie sagen so einfach ist
das nicht ein kernkraftwerk mit einer
neuen genehmigung zu versehen ich das
wird ganz schwierig aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen möglicherweise
geprägt wenn man will kann man eine
menge erreichen ja aber nicht hören wozu
sich das reicht ja wenn das mit jahres
im griff haben denn da laufen die
letzten erst aus noch ein wort nun also
wenn sie den leuten sagen wenn so ein
ding in die luft geht dann werden sich
alle zurückschrecken uns werden sagen
nee nee dann lieber nicht
wir haben die damals genehmigt weil sie
wussten die deutschen meiler sind mit
die sichersten teilweise aus starb sie
heute noch so sind nicht nur sich nicht
bei uns ist kein tsunami bei uns ist
kein fukushima das waren stimmungs
entscheidung dieser koalition an der ahr
leider die fdp beteiligt war nämlich mit
guido westerwelle eine der unglücklichen
entscheidung die da getroffen worden
sind das war falsch aber zu hören
der zweite runde punkt die nicht
feststellen bei der diskussion der ampel
ich habe nicht nur den eindruck das war
dann gesagt wird diskutiert aber wir
diskutieren so dass etwas gar nicht
stattfinden kann ich habe auch den
eindruck dass man ihr zunehmend den
ukraine konflikt und die damit
verbundenen energie sorgen die wir haben
nutzt um sagen und jetzt muss man noch
schneller den die energiewende betreiben
den klimawandel vorantreiben ich sage
nur in dem oster paket von herrn habeck
steht eine zielsetzung für die
vollversorgung mit ökostrom
20 33 im koalitionsvertrag den habe ich
nämlich gelesen steht 2045 jetzt hat die
ampel sich geeinigt das ding kommt ein
bundestag ist es wie jetzt beim rümpfen
jetzt soll der bundestag die lager so
wir wollten weil die ampel die digital
controls wasmeiers zahlen niveau im co2
neutral in deutschland bis 2045 sein und
bis 2035 soll der strom bestehe unions
vertrauen so erhalt bitte lesen
vielleicht kurz ergänzung wir finden das
ja auch gut wenn wenn gewiss durch eure
umstände der druck wächst und das
beschleunigt aber die königs halt nicht
wenn sie brauchen wenn die heizungen
austauschen sie kriegen doch moment das
ich kann es aus eigener erfahrung sagen
in dem jahr gibt es keinen der mir
bereitet habe ungefähr zehn angefragt in
dem jahr gibt es keinen der bereit ist
die haltung auszutauschen die handwerker
sind völlig überlastet die leute wollen
man kann diese krise so bitter es ist
sozusagen nutzen für eine anstehende
transformation aber sie werden es nicht
von heute auf morgen hinkriegen da haben
sie einfach die handwerker nicht es
dauert mehrere jahre und deshalb wäre
dieser vorschlag gewesen ja jetzt in der
tinte also man muss ja wirklich sagen
wir sitzen jetzt gerade energiepolitisch
absolut in der tinte und es waren ja
auch schon verbände vor blackouts also
ich bin da ehrlich gesagt weil brähmer
da muss man doch jetzt alles möglich
machen das irgendwie kilo co2 budget ja
ja was wir jetzt in die luft geben
bleibt ewig da über unser leben hinaus
also wenn wir jetzt verantwortungsvoll
handeln müssen haben wir nur noch einen
geringen spieler habe ich auch lange
gebraucht um das zu begreifen also das
heißt wir müssen die transformation
schaffen auch jetzt unter erschwerten
bedingungen und wir müssen den krieg
schaffen der kostet knapp wird und sehr
viel kosten werden in eine werden eine
enge kaum auch mit unserer lebenshaltung
wir werden wohlstandsverlust haben das
muss wohl der bevölkerung gesagt werden
das sind ja 100 aufgaben die
klimageschichte ist eine
jahrhundertaufgabe
und ich also herr bremer ich habe das
nicht immer allzu studiert aber was der
hupac daten ziel vorlegte ist meines
erachtens nicht nimmt denn er
blendet doch die ökonomische
notwendigkeit die den damit verbunden
sein muss und auch die sozialen aspekte
nicht aus ich war sie würden als union
reicht doch wenn ich die möglichkeit
dass es gibt nachteile im südlichen den
kollegen mit dem stock doch auch ich
habe ja gesagt wir unterstützen den
transformationsprozess nur wir werden
inhalt nicht von heute auf morgen
schnitt lösen
auch das paket ist eine familie mit zwei
kindern 800 euro eine 800 euro
erleichterung davon für zwei
arbeitnehmer und zwei kinder also
zweimal 300 und 2 x 200 einfach mal
unter tage stelle letzte woche war jetzt
vorher für 4500 liter waren vorher 25
ist jetzt für 1500 2000
familien haben auch oft alte häuser da
gibt es oft noch eine ölheizung also
nicht das nicht so
nerlich wir können als stadt nicht alle
krisen dieser welt querfinanziert wir
können den schock abfangen dem schock
dieser preissteigerung das müssen wir
auch erklärt ich habe einen meiner leute
weniger als 1500 euro im monat netto
also ich weiß was es heißt mir leute
wenig geld haben das sind die meisten
meiner wähler und da bin ich auch sehr
hinterher dass da auch was getan wird
und dann bin ich auch sehr froh dass wir
die drei mal dass sprit im mäßigen
tankstelle erreicht haben über die
senkung der mineralölsteuer auf das eu
minimum aber wir können das nicht auf
die dauer finanzieren wenn sie sagen
immer mehr mehr mehr wir brauchen noch
mehr entlastung sie wissen ganz genau so
etwas im haushalt die spieler für mich
sind das ist nicht finanzierbar ist
haben sie mir verlängerung oder gar
nicht wird sie haben wir mit zehn
punkten sehr im prinzip stimmt es ja
auch der finanzminister sagt ja zu recht
der staat kann ich alles abfedern
das ist völlig richtig
aber machen sie dann den leuten auch
wirklich klar was es heißt wenn das
nicht möglich ist wir leben eigentlich
in einer zeit der vollkasko mentalität
unter anderem auch durch 16 jahre immer
mal wieder große koalition ein bisschen
mitgeprägt die leute erwarten
unsicherheit jetzt gutes beim
steueraufkommen der hilft mir der kann
das jetzt nicht der kann ich 100
milliarden mal für die bundeswehr locker
machen was dringend notwendig ist damit
die mehrwerte tauglich wird der kann
nicht alles andere auch noch abfedern
ich wette mit ihnen wenn sie die klare
brutale wahrheit sagen den bürgern dann
ist das mit der zustimmung zu viel nicht
mehr so dolle diese müssen aber sie
müssen sie ihm soll ich hatte halt
vorbei ok wo ich bei ihnen bin wir
müssen das sozial abfedern also ich
meine diese wir haben nach dem kriege
das weiß kaum jemand wir haben nach dem
ausgleich gehabt ja wir haben übrigens
liga bei besitzenden haben die hälfte
abgegeben das beliebte plädieren
letztlich dafür aber wir kommen eine
situation wo wir ganz andere lasten
verkaufen herr baum sie haben die
regenunterbrechung gehen sie kennen das
bestimmt auch vom leider ganz
wahrscheinlich auch unterbrechungen wir
haben einen ganz kurz und dann sind wir
gleich an dem wir müssen natürlich auch
geld verdienen das völlig richtig wir
sind gleich wieder zerreden